la britannique martin merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors un
préavis de grève a été déposé pour la
journée qu'elles vont peut-être les
actions prévues aujourd'hui
alors tout d'abord merci à vous quoi
appuyer toujours une grosse pensée à la
famille de décider chez nous qui nous a
quittés tout d'abord donc les actions
donc nous sommes arrivés au dépôt de
giberville depuis 4 heures 4h15 95 donc
si vous arrivez donc des produits frais
mme camille bloqué le dépôt de
giberville débloquer le dépôt dont
l'évêque est bloqué tous les camions
sont sur le site de giberville
bon qu'est ce que nous comptons faire
c'est aller voir les communautés de
communes de coeur de nacre et de caen la
mer pour dénoncer tout ce qui se passe
dans cette entreprise et donc il n'y a
aucun dialogue social il ya aucun
dialogue social même après la mort de
notre collègue nous avons eu aucun
soutien de notre entreprise pour
l'instant juste était plutôt discrète
dans cette affaire en tout cas depuis le
début de cette affaire est là elle
réagit pourtant la semaine dernière je
cite il est de notre responsabilité que
les dons que pendant que ces chauffeurs
ne constitue pas un danger
comment vous réagissez à ses propos de
la direction ou le venteuse car comment
qu'on peut dire ça qu'on peut laisser un
chausseur comme ils ont dû repartir avec
les camions c'est même eux qui l'ont
laissé repartir avec le camion bon
comment comptes-tu à dire des choses
pareilles si les choses de fausses comme
d'habitude et comment vous réagissez
forcément à cette discrétion aussi de la
part de votre direction
la réaction je viens de vous citer
est récente et c'est la seule c'est bien
ça oui oui c'est la seule oui on a oui
c'est là solidaires en étant en réunion
avec la direction 1
et voilà on a parlé du dialogue social
qui manquait dans l'entreprise on a dû
plusieurs points on nous a répondu que
j'aurai une réunion hebdomadaire
donc on est ok pour ça ensuite on va
parler de nos salaires bien évidemment
des salaires qu'on demande depuis trois
ans il ya aucune augmentation donc dans
des choses quand même et la direction ça
a répondu clairement au bout d'une demi
heure ils ont staut à la réunion doute
une des mères ils sont volonté nous
indiquons profiter de l'apport de notre
collecte pour demander une augmentation
donc on a trouvé ça aberrant de leur
part une fois de plus que c'est la
direction comment peut-on profiter de la
mort d'un collègue maintenance et vous
imaginez c'est impressionnant ce qu'ils
osent dire on n'a jamais profité de la
mort de notre collègue pour demander une
augmentation de salaire puisque ça fait
trois ans qu'on la demande ensuite on
nous a dit oui mais attention vous avez
une prime de 750 euros mais cette prime
n'a rien à voir puisque la prime qu'on a
eu c'est la prime pour le travail qu'on
l'a fait pour le colis de 19 s être
honnête on est ce que espoir pour vous
là la réaction de l'entreprise de votre
entreprise de nice en cire ce salarié
justement était trop radicale
et qu'aurait pu être les autres
solutions mais bien sûr ce qu'ils
auraient dû faire quand même si au moins
de parler avec ces personnes et en plus
ils ont lu et c'est l'histoire de
continuer dans l'entreprise puisqu'ils
ont laissé travailler jusqu'au fameux
jeudi 4 mai et le jeudi 4 mai il a reçu
sa lettre de licenciement pourquoi on
l'a fait travailler alors on avec
admettent en mise à pied conservatoire
et le dire c'est fini vous triez plus
chez nous mais faut savoir quand même
que la direction dit on est obligé de
licencier les gens qui boivent sur le
temps de travail mais sans savoir que la
coréenne et licencient pas spécialement
pour ça la connaît
ils ont aussi parce que vous prenez une
poubelle à gauche de la route jetten la
cua les conti licenciés mais je suis
toujours en procédure dont on pouvait
les ramasser du côté de la route on sait
qu pas de la ligue familles des gens ils
sont ici sont pas là pour eux au moins
j'ai parlé avec mon directeur du
territoire elle a dit qu'il n'était pas
là pour faire du social
on se sent comme en cent mais sans
vraiment en colère
ils ont collé des personnes aujourd'hui
mais non mais beaucoup on a perdu un
autre de temps mais on a perdu un
collègue qui était inconnu que j'étais
un tout
il a perdu je pense qu'ils auraient
quand même pu parler à stephano en
l'union ce qui est assez c'est pas bien
ce que tu recommences mais le problème
vous voyez c'est une personne qui a eu
une fille à pied en 26 ans de travail et
de cliquer à la coved ça c'est 50 il à
la cueillette du gui cette mise à pied
c'est pourquoi carla changéens main sur
un planning on lui a mis une mise à pied
d'une journée
voyez c'est radical c'est les sanctions
radicales je trouve ça lamentable de la
part de l'entreprise
il n'y a aucun dialogue social merci
beaucoup yannick martin d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin merci beaucoup je rappelle
que moi êtes élu cgt de l'entreprise
coved merci